Jeopardy just had a major switch up with
Mayim Bialik bailing on the show in the
middle of a season why here's what went
down following the death of Alex Trebek
Jeopardy returned to television screens
with a revolving door of guest hosts the
iconic game show ultimately landed on
the Big Bang Theory star Mayim Bialik
and game show personality Ken Jennings
as its two rotating hosts when she
originally started off as a guest host
Bialik described working on the show as
an unbelievable honor in an interview
with today saying I'm especially honored
to be able to represent women who love
game shows and facts and all things geek
especially when they combine with
something as entertaining as Jeopardy
Bialik and Jennings assumed their
official permanent hosting roles in 2021
and have vasked in the glory since
ushering the show into season 39. Bialik
however has made a striking choice that
will impact the rest of the season she
is stepping away from her Jeopardy
hosting duties why like other Hollywood
creatives Bialik is choosing to stand in
solidarity with the writer's Guild of
America's striking workers while not a
member of the wga Bialik is a member of
The Screen Actors Guild American
Federation of television and radio
artists a union that continues to
express its support for Riders on strike
with only a handful of episodes left to
film before the summer Hiatus Jennings
will take over hosting Jeopardy duties
and be all extead the wga strike began
on May 2nd 2023 questions for season 39
of Jeopardy were written in advance of
the strike but the game show still
features contributions from wga writers
it's unclear how besides Ken Jennings
taking over as host the final batch of
episodes and their scripts will be
impacted deadline confirms that Jeopardy
writers and wga members Michelle loud
Jim Ryan and Billy Weiss are currently
on strike the Jeopardy scribes were seen
picketing at Sony picture studios in
Culver City on May 6th where they
candidly discussed their issues with
variety loud told the outlet our words
are on the screen every night there is
no Jeopardy without writers without us
it's just an empty blue screen loud
Rhine and Weiss have lent their balance
to Jeopardy for over two decades helping
shape its Legacy our head writer Billy
did not even have to look it up April
30th 1789. that's why we keep him around
Mark gaberman another Jeopardy writer
took to Twitter to thank Mayim Bialik
for supporting the wga he wrote this
means more to us than we could ever say
thank you so much Ken Jennings will film
Jeopardy season 39's final batch of
episodes from May 16th to 19th Jennings
decision has proven to be controversial
with many labeling the game show host as
a scab a term used for those who work
during strikes one Twitter user wrote
gained respect from IEM Bialik and lost
it for Ken Jennings don't be a scab
another user also expressed
disappointment at the news as well
saying simply Ken isn't Jeopardy the
Jeopardy writers are Jeopardy others
have been more sympathetic to Jennings
Who Rose to prominence after winning 74
consecutive games on the show one person
wrote on Reddit Ken is making the right
choice here there are a lot of people
who would lose their paycheck if no one
shows up to host the user continued by
pointing out how Mayim Bialik has duties
as a sag member to support the wga weeks
before the strike began Jennings took to
Twitter on April 17 to show his own
support for wga members many Jeopardy
fans on social media continue to
speculate as to why Jennings is staying
on as host and if his decision to do so
is for the benefit of the show's crew
which boasts countless non-writing staff
members per the show's credits
[Music]